Mark Ruffalo's Hulk will smash again in
the MCU at least that's the word coming
from the folks at the Illuminati as the
site is claiming that sources close to
Disney plus and Marvel's upcoming
she-hulk series have provided definitive
proof that Ruffalo is officially on
board to reprise his role as Bruce
Banner on the small screen a kick-ass
new hero and a returning fan favorites
best of both worlds it should be noted
of course that the site does not provide
said proof for the masses to see nor do
they actually say what that proof is one
would have to imagine they've seen
Ruffalo signature on an actual contract
for it to count as definitive either way
it still might be wise for MCU
enthusiasts to temper their excitement
about hoax return until Team Marvel
makes their own announcement that news
would hardly come as a shock though as
it's been widely rumored in recent weeks
that Ruffalo's big green guy would
indeed be joining the anxiously
anticipated she-hulk series Screen Rant
reports that Ruffalo himself even
recently confirmed that he was in talks
with Marvel and Disney to reprise his
role as banner / Hulk for the Disney
Plus series seems those talks might have
been a bit further along that Ruffalo
was letting on as the Illuminati is now
reporting the actors deal was likely
already in place when he made those
comments there's still no confirmation
as to how many episodes of she-hulk
Ruffalo might appear in or if his new
deal with Marvel might include another
big screen turn in the future but
whatever the case we're just psyched to
see Ruffalo Hulk on screen again in any
capacity if you recall Mark Ruffalo took
over the role of Hulk after folks at
Marvel famously parted ways with og MCU
hulk edward norton making his first
appearance at 2012's The Avengers
Ruffalo immediately made the role his
own now it might be a really good time
for you to get angry
that's my secret captain
I'm always angry he continued to play
Bruce Banner and Hulk and for subsequent
MCU flicks not including uncredited
cameo appearances Marvel's brass are
clearly fans and have now reportedly
ensured that no other actor will play
Hulk for the foreseeable future
as for what role Bruce Banner will play
in she-hulk if the Disney plus series
stays true to characters comic book
origins his role could be fairly major
for those unfamiliar with she-hulk the
character's name is Jennifer Walters and
she's a successful attorney often for
the superhero set she also just happens
to be Bruce banners cousin if you're
wondering how Walters become she-hulk
the transformation occurs after she
receives a blood transfusion from dear
cousin Bruce after which she finds
herself with a similar green affliction
although she actually Hulk's out with
her intellect and self-control intact
how's this Wolters eventually becomes a
member of the Avengers and a force and
she continues to play a major role in
Marvel Comics so you can likely expect
to see a lot more the character as the
MCU charges ahead as for what that could
entail well Marvel Studios would be
remiss not to use Walters career as an
attorney a seven-foot Korean attorney
that is as a way to introduce her to the
wider MCU the studio's head honcho Kevin
Feige has already made it quite clear
that characters introduced to be a
Disney plus series will be making
appearances in future films and we can
think of a hero / - who might be in need
of legal representation in the very near
future case in point
Peter Parker who was just publicly outed
as spider-man and framed for an
extremely high-profile murder and who
suddenly has some blowhard named Jay
jonah Jameson ranting about what a
menace he is spider-man a psychopath
wielding powers he has no right to
possess trying to pass himself off as a
hero you're no hero as for banner well
for all we know his stint on she-hulk
could be a one-off deal that sees him
supplying the necessary Hulk blood to
facilitate his cousin's transformation
and going on his merry green way we're
not so secretly hoping though that this
news means that Ruffalo still has a
vital role to play in future phases of
the MCU she-hulk has not yet received an
official release date by production on
the series is expected to begin in July
we'll keep an eye out for an official
announcement and we'll be sure to keep
you informed
o go check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]